the year 2008 the problem Oakland has
too many guns the solution offer $250
for every gun turned into to the police
no questions asked sounds like a great
idea with the best of intentions what
could possibly go wrong a lot of guns
aren't worth $250 but they were that day
people drove for hours even from other
states to sell their old junk that had
been collecting dust not the kind of
weapons used to perpetrate a crime in
fact the first two people in line at one
of the buyback locations were gun
dealers unloading their worthless stock
the program was estimated to cost
$50,000 but the police department
quickly ran out of cash and had to issue
IUS totaling roughly
$170,000 and it would have been even
more expensive except that Oakland had
essentially created an openair gun
Market some guns were actually bought by
prospective buyers walking the line and
offering $300 for specialty items talk
about a misfire